[Music]
Hello.
I still remember the first line of code
that I wrote. It was on this computer, a
Compact 95. And I also remember the
feeling that I had when I wrote my first
program. It was one of magic because for
the first time, I created something more
beautiful and far more interesting than
I can do by myself. And I've thought
about that moment ever since.
I've spent the last 15 years building
some of the most important products in
machine learning. And now I have the
opportunity to lead our core AI platform
at Microsoft. And our goal is to empower
every single person in this room to use
AI to shape the world.
Now, I'm excited to be here to talk to
all of you, but I'm most excited because
I love the World Fair. The World Fair is
where imagination and impact start to
collapse. And that's happened throughout
the last century. In 1939, it was the
first time that Hollywood came into our
living rooms. In 1964, faces came over
the copper wires. And today, it's all
about agents. agents that can learn,
that can adapt, that can extend the way
that we live. And most importantly, it's
fundamentally changing how we actually
make product. So, how did we get here?
Well, over the last few years, we've
seen a change in the model landscape.
There used to just be a handful of
models from one provider, and now,
thanks to many people in this room,
there's been an explosion of reasoning
models. And that explosion is giving way
to new capability and new efficiency. We
see that a lot of models can now
generate hypotheses, understand
unstructured data, even act at a PhD
level in certain domains.
We also know that these models are
becoming more efficient. They don't just
live in data centers anymore. They live
on our laptops. We have full control and
there's no latency. And so this is
starting to birth what we call the
agentic web. a world in which agents are
going to interact with tools and models
and probably other agents. And they're
going to do so no matter what cloud
they're on, no matter what company built
them, no matter what device that you
choose to use. And underlying this, it's
creating a few different forces in the
world of AI engineering.
The first is that we're going from pair
programming to peer programming. Copilot
used to be a sidekick and now it's an
actual teammate.
The second is that we're going from a
software factory to the agent factory.
It's not just about binaries anymore.
It's about behaviors.
And the third thing that we're seeing is
that models don't just live in the cloud
anymore. They live on your device and
they can follow you wherever you are
to sustain this. I don't think there's
any one tool that we need. Instead, I
think it's a platform of AI powered
tools that are going to sit on top of an
agent factory that every company is
going to have, that has trust and
security baked in, and that goes from
cloud to edge seamlessly. So, let's dive
in.
Now, as far as I can remember,
programming has always been a
partnership between the person and the
machine. We would write lines of code
and the machine would execute it. But
now, we're starting to see a world where
the machine can write the code. It can
fix itself. It can help you imagine new
features. And so with that, our entire
day is changing. The workflow is
changing.
The old world used to be us shephering
syntax. And in this new world, GitHub
Copilot can now live in your codebase.
It operates in your branch. You can
assign a task to it and it can run tests
until it's complete. That means we're
going to spend more time on
architectural decisions, more time
orchestrating teams of agents.
Maintenance is changing, too. In the old
world, maintenance would compete with
features. I hated that world. And in
this new world, what we're seeing is the
opportunity to invent agents that can
continuously improve your codebase. And
that's why we invented something called
FSY. You can think about it as graph rag
for your codebase. It can reason over
it, can explain it, and it can
continuously improve it and even fix
some areas.
Another area that I'm really excited
about is GitHub as a peer.
Now in the past it would have generic AI
was just operating on a generic codebase
but now because we have open sourced the
extension for GitHub copilot GitHub
copilot now understands your patterns it
understands your domains it understands
your teams and so it can effectively
speak your own language and so instead
of designing backwards you can build
forward.
Now, I was told that you all like live
demos and so instead of talking about
this, I thought I would invite my friend
Seth Wararez up to show you some of our
AI power tools. So, Seth, hey, how's it
going, my friends? They uh closed my
laptop, so I'm going to open it here.
Um, I'm on demo one. And one of the
things about uh development is there's a
couple of tasks that are kind of
tedious, right? So, I'm going to show
you how AI can make three of these kinds
of things a lot easier to do. Number
one, when you get started on a project,
you always have a thousand questions and
no one to ask. I'll show you how GitHub
spaces makes this a little bit easier.
Number two, crushing your first task.
How do you get started on a task on a
brand new project? I'll show you how.
And then number three, diving deep. All
right, so let's start with
understanding. There is a new feature
called co-pilot spaces. And the cool
thing about co copilot spaces is is that
you can actually create a co-pilot
space. Give it some uh a prompt some
instructions and then you can also
ground it in a bunch of different files.
You're going to see a project later on
uh uh in live that's going to show you
this. Uh but one of the things I want to
ask it is for example is this really an
agentic project? You're going to see a
live multi- aent voice thing in a
second. And this is the project. So I'm
going to go ahead and hit enter. And the
thing about GitHub Copilot now grounded
in spaces is that it can answer any
question that's grounded in the actual
facts of the project. So you can create
as many spaces as you want. They never
get tired of answering questions.
They're not only do they give you really
good answers like what does a Gentic
really mean? Great answer. It also gives
you the code of where it actually does
the thing. So you're able to right away
get started in understanding your
project. That's number one. Number two,
crushing your first task. This is a
project we released uh a couple of weeks
ago and what somebody literally was
like, "Hey, because I you know how you
make a demo and then you put it out and
there someone always is like, "Hey, um
can you write a readme?"
I said no. And I signed it to Copilot
and it did it. Let me show you what that
looks like. So, I'm going to go ahead
and create a new issue here. And this
issue is going to be like an
architecture uh diary. That's why I need
more better setup instructions, right?
And I'm going to give it some
descriptions. Let me show you how easy
it is to crush your first task. I'm
going to assign it to co-pilot. And
that's it. Watch the eyeballs right
here. In a second, you're going to see
little eyeballs just And now it's
working. And by the way, this is
actually happening live. This isn't like
me faking it or anything. And let me go
back to this actual project. It did the
work for me. It takes a couple of
minutes, but I don't have that kind of
time here. And let me show you the file
that it made for me in GitHub. Uh the
the actual uh um GitHub copilot coding
assistant coding agent. It made this
whole thing for me. You can oo a little
bit. Yeah. Oo yeah. Yeah. This is
delightful. You can clap to this is
great. I didn't have to write this.
Number two, crushing your first task.
And then number three, diving deep. It
turns out that if you've seen GitHub uh
copilot inside of Visual Studio Code,
you can actually extend Copilot to talk
to other agents and we did just that
with Omaly. There's a there's another
task that I have here that was assigned
to me. Let me go over here to the issues
uh that says I need a new we need a new
agent that reasons about housing. That
sounds like a deep task. So, we're going
to use GitHub Copilot to help us here.
I'm going to say can you help me predict
the housing prices? And as this goes,
what's actually happening is GitHub
Copilot and Visual Studio Code is
talking to another agent called Amaly
MLE machine learning engineer agent that
has two agents that can reason about
what you're asking and can also write
code. So I'm going to go ahead and get
this one, this file here, this file
here. Let me close it. I'm going to move
this over here and say yes, these are
the files. And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say yeah, use these files.
I don't want I don't want to use this
file. So I'm going to say use use these
files. So number,
can you use these files? And what it's
going to do is it's going to look at
this file as if it was a machine
learning engineer. It's going to reason
about the actual contents of the file,
and I can ask it any question about
anything that I want. And I'm I'm kind
of out of time, so I want to show you
the output of this thing. It literally
builds an entire machine learning model
for me. And you're like, "Oh, it made a
mistake." Did it? Uh you can see here uh
mistake. What was the mistake? Oh,
somebody put a string in the float
place. Yeah. And it knew about that and
it fixed it. So there you go. I showed
you three things. Jumping into a
project, understanding it, crushing your
first task, and diving deep, all with
the help of AI. Back to you, Washa.
All right. Thank you, Seth.
So both of those agents that you just
saw were built on something called
Foundry. And underneath the covers of
GitHub and all of these new agents is
there's a bigger change that's
happening. We're going from shipping
binaries and neat releases to shipping
agents that can retrain and redeploy and
change after they're live. And so we've
been thinking about what is the best way
to do that and studying patterns. And
something new is emerging called a
signals loop. It's the idea that you can
get better results if you actually
fine-tune the model to personalize it to
your outcome. Something that we've long
talked about, but we're actually seeing
it in the results. So our platform not
only supports 70,000 customers with
Foundry, but we also support every
single co-pilot in the company that is
built. And this one is called Dragon.
Dragon is the leading healthcare
co-pilot out there. It helps you uh
automate scribing and other things to
give physicians more time to give
patient care. They took an off-the-shelf
model and it was pretty good. Uh they
tried to synthetically fine-tune it to
make it better and it got a little bit
better, but then they took 650,000
interactions and they did a bunch of AB
testing and we got to an 83% character
acceptance rate. So dramatically better
quality. And so as we think about what
this actual signal loop requires, it
means that we're going from this linear
software factory to a continuous loop
that we need to build for. And that's
really what we built Foundry to do. We
believe that the entire infrastructure
is changing to build these agentic
applications and these agentic systems.
We don't have time to go through all of
these, so I'm just going to go through a
few of them and how they're changing,
but models. We believe that no one model
is right for every single product. And
in often oftentimes the best products
have an ensemble or a mixture of models
that are finely tuned for every single
job to be done. And so we've built a
switchboard and intelligent routing so
you can have access to 10,000 open
models and proprietary models and be
able to have it backed by the security
and reliability and the data residency
that you need.
on knowledge. I think I heard that uh
rag was that. So rag is used in 50% of
applications today for AI. Um but it's
singleshot and it it's pretty naive. And
so we've rolled out something called
agentic rag. It's the idea that you can
kind of go around and iterate and
evaluate and plan. It's multi-shot. And
what we're seeing is a 40% improvement
and accuracy on complex queries.
We all know that tooling is changing.
Tooling is becoming infrastructure. You
need more than text to build a good
agent. You need the code. You need the
containers. And we have that as well. We
have more than 1500 tools. We were one
of the first to adopt MCP and a and A2A.
And finally, agents and intelligence is
only good if you can actually hold it
accountable. And so we are rolling out
aggressive efforts in this area. We have
the leading evaluations SDK, the leading
red teaming agents. And we believe that
telemetry is an optional. We've
integrated with hotel and we have
continuous observability no matter if
you've built your agent on our platform
or you built it somewhere else. Today
more than 50,000 agents are built every
single day using our loop on our
platform. Now the platform is modular
but we've also made an effort for it to
be open. And I want to talk to you about
a couple of things on the open side that
I'm really excited about. The first is
Gigapath. It is the first model of its
kind. It's an open model and it's the
first one that can understand a
pathology slide. Pathology slide has a
100,000 pixels by 100,000 pixels if you
printed it out would be the size of a
tennis court. It's the first one that
can understand it without downsampling
or linting. And it does that because
we've used dilated attention which is a
technique we borrowed from speech
modeling. And so now you can understand
how to build an immune tumor environment
without doing it in patches without the
macro environment. You can do it at a
micro level for the first time. And
that's an open model on our platform.
Obviously, everybody's following Deep
Seek and there was an update to the R1
model a couple of days ago. Uh that
update is on our platform today on
Foundry, backed by all of our security
and safety for all of you to use.
And finally, we're continuing to invest
in A2A and MCP and all of the open
protocols. I think the big thing for us
to think about is that we believe that
these protocols will continue to come
along and they're going to be popular
and we're going to support them all. so
you can work with the tools that you
love.
Now, I want to show you how simple it is
to build an agent, but not just one,
multiple agents that are useful. We've
got another demo. Please welcome Amanda
and Elijah.
[Applause]
What better way to showcase our Foundry
Agent Factory than by demonstrating it
live than taking you behind the scenes
with us to build the agents and ensure
they're safe and secure. Before we dive
into our multi- aent application, let's
go over to demo three where Elijah is
going to show you how to build a single
agent in VS Code. Awesome. So, jumping
right into VS Code, you guys will notice
that I have installed the Azure AI
Foundry extension. This extension is
awesome because it allows us to see all
of the models, agents, as well as
threads that I have associated with my
project. And I want to take a moment
here to talk about threads. As you guys
know, threads is an integral part of
agents, and it's critical for the
transparency aspect of being able to see
what the agent is doing at each step of
the way. So, here I can see a thread
that Amanda created earlier that's
saying, "Hey, Elijah's a product
manager. Can you send him a personalized
email?" And we'll be using a
personalized email agent today. So, then
it receives from a contact list. It
sends us some information. And what's
great about this is that I can see the
tool calls that it's used as well as
some information around prompting and
and tokens. So, that's great. Then I can
look at the actual agent which I can see
here and we have the ID, the name, the
system prompt as well as the tools are
being used. Now that's great in the UI
but let's jump right into the actual
code of how we built this. So going in
here you can see I'm using the Azure AI
foundry uh agent service SDK that Asha
just talked to us about. So I'm initial
initializing that using the our project
client creating the actual agent and
then giving it a set of tools. And so
today in the agent service we have a
bunch of different tools. Today we're
using the Bing grounding tool, the file
search tool, and the open API tool. But
what's great is that I could use a
variety of tools here. I could use MCP
servers. I could use external APIs and I
could even use other agents using the
Foundry uh connected agent tool. And
then I create the agent, use the model,
and then give it some instructions. And
then finally, I can execute this agent
here. And it's important to also note
that I'm executing a foundry agent, but
I could use a wide variety of agents
here. I could use lang chain agents. I
know our friends from lane chain are
here today. I could use crew AI agents
um or even as Asha mentioned multiple
agents using ADA protocol. So this is
awesome. But now let's see these agents
in action. Yeah. Now let's switch over
to demo 2 again and dive into our app.
So build events is a multi- aent event
planner application powered by a voice
controlled agentic orchestrator that
dynamically delegates tasks to sub
agents we built using our foundry agent
service at Microsoft build. We showed
how this app could actually help us plan
a hackathon in San Francisco for 200
people. But truthfully this can help us
plan any type of event. And today we're
going to show how we could actually use
it to per plan and prepare for investor
meetings at the AI World Fair in San
Francisco. So let's dive into it.
First we are going to ask it who we
should be connecting with.
How can I assist you with your event
planning needs today?
Find top angel investors backing pre-
seriesa AI native SAS startups who are
attending the AI engineering world fair
in San Francisco.
I'm gathering information on the top
angel investors attending the event. Is
there anything else you'd like to know
or plan while I continue this task? As
you can see, our first agent is now hard
at work. This is the research agent. We
provided it access to the entire speaker
list as well as some attendees that had
said online that they were coming and it
has access to search to the web using
our Bing grounding tool. So let's see
what this comes up with. And everything
you're seeing today is completely live.
So bear with us. Send information on top
angel investors who are attending the AI
engineering world. Send a personalized
email to Asha Sharma now asking to
connect at the event.
I'm drafting a personalized email to
connect with Asha Sharma at the event.
Is there anything else you'd like me to
include or any other assistance you
need? So, as you can see, our email to
Asha Sharma has been drafted focusing on
opportunities in AI native SAS startups
and potential collaboration. Would you
like to proceed with any other tasks?
The email draft to Asha Sharma is ready.
Awesome. Now, could you take a live
photo of Elijah and I and edit us to be
AI agents? Um, cartoon-like. Think Azure
OpenAI meets Pixar.
Please go ahead and click on the camera
icon to take a live photo. The image
will be transformed into a cartoon-like
style depicting you both as AI. In the
meantime, could you also draft some
content asking or saying we'll be in San
Francisco and are happy to meet with
anyone at the World Fair to talk about
AI agents?
I'm drafting LinkedIn content to
announce your presence at the AI
engineering world's fair and your
eagerness to connect with others to
discuss AI agents. The image will be
ready shortly as well. Look at that
LinkedIn content announcing your
presence at the AI engineering world.
This looks great. Could you now post
both this image and the draft to
LinkedIn?
The LinkedIn post with the edited image
is being published. Is there anything
else you'd like assistance with?
And so now what tools it using to do
this, Amanda? So right now we actually
in this past sequence had two agents be
kicked off simultaneously. One was gen
generating and editing our image and
then the second agent was drafting the
content. Your LinkedIn post has been
lived
image
I can help you with just let me know.
And as you can see the post is now live.
Amazing. That's awesome. Yeah. Now, back
to Elijah. One quick final note, Asha,
you talked about earlier how important
evaluations are. So, if we want to go to
demo three really quick here at Azure
OpenAI agent service, we're committed to
making sure that our agents are
consistently delivering high quality
results. So, as Asha mentioned earlier
and we actually about the uh evaluation
SDK, we integrated this right into our
CI/CD pipeline so that we can be able to
evaluate our agents every time we make
updates. So, you saw today how to
create, use, and now evaluate agents.
And with that, we'll turn it right back
over to you, Asha. Thanks so much.
Thanks, guys.
We didn't know how that would go
yesterday. The internet wasn't working.
So, uh, that's amazing. And I also have
had about 15 emails from Amanda over the
last 24 hours, uh, which I appreciate.
Okay, I uh we have to we have to go
quickly here, but uh look, one of the
last big things I want to talk to you
about is how models don't just live in
the cloud. Even for the last 10 years,
we've been working really hard to do
that because that's where your data is.
Your data is now everywhere. Um and this
isn't just a hobbyist thing. We are
seeing real applications of this at
scale. Um, I was just at a bottling
plant and there's an agent there that is
taking 100,000 sensors per second and
allowing it to actually detect risks and
flag and throw the summaries in the
cloud. We're building an agent right now
for a hospital system that basically
summarizes the longitudinal data. Uh,
and if you work in healthcare, you know
that that can't be in the cloud. It has
to be local because of compliance and
privacy reasons, but the cloud should be
able to read it and access it. And we're
working with automobile companies
because they're building uh automotive
models that we want to work in tunnels
and then we want it to actually make
your trip better and smarter. And so
with all of this local cannot be uh a
fork. It has to be a core part of the
platform. You should be able to create
an agent in the cloud and it should run
and act and reason uh locally. And so
I've got one more demo. Uh Seth is
coming back out and then we will wrap
up. Seth, why don't you show us how to
get local?